allen one guy who's been around the nfl
for a long time now
2007 was his rookie season adrian
peterson turns 36
next month he continues to talk about
two objectives one is either easier than
the other one is winning a super bowl
the other one is much harder that's
catching emmett smith and taking the
all-time rushing record here's the
latest from adrian peterson on his
lingering desire
to pass emmett smith
it's something that i'm mindful of like
okay it's only i know it's about three
thirty eight hundred four thousand or
something like that so i know that much
um but i'm just gonna keep playing
you know i'm gonna keep playing trying
to chase the championship and guys
willing
within that process of doing that i'm
able to catch
emin and pass him i want to set the bar
at a different level you know i want to
literally be a 40-year-old back
out there rushing for 1500 yards you
know and
amazing people still
i got to admire the attitude and it's
kind of what we're talking about we
continue to go about our lives with our
goals with our dreams day in and day out
it doesn't really matter if you get
there or not
it's just having them is what gets you
through times like this
is he gonna get 3535 yards
i don't think so he'd have to play five
more years he wants to play into the age
of 40. that's five more seasons he needs
to average 707 yards per season he had
600
and some change not much change for the
lions in
2020. he's got a long way to go he's got
several guys he's got to jump
i i say you know the
the will is there the determination is
there the problem is the employment
needs to be there you need to have a
team
you need to be on the field you need to
be getting the ball
i i think if if he would get you know
250 carries a year
or 200 a year he's going to get there
but i don't know that he's going to
continue to find employment i don't know
that he's going to continue to find
opportunities almost like frank gore i
think frank gore would catch emmett
smith
if teams would continue to give him work
miles it's just it's hard with with
young guys full tread on the tires
coming out every year of college
it's harder and harder for the older
running backs to find jobs
yeah why would anybody necessarily sign
adrian peterson
in free agency in march in april in may
when at really at most i think his best
role for somebody that a team would
probably be
as somebody who can come in at a
contender
and maybe help them be a third down back
or somebody who can
get the ball in the end zone when
they're down there in the red zone i
just
i don't see him as a pure starting
running back anymore and i think that's
what he would need to be
in order to get that 700 yards per
season
and sort of be this tom brady of running
backs that he apparently wants to be
where he's playing at 40 and he's
getting all these carries and then he's
getting into the end zone i mean mike
who can you actually think of that would
want to sign him as a free agent
in him when he was released by
washington but they wanted to wait until
after their week one game against the
texans because
there's a quirk in the rules that if you
sign a vested veteran after week one and
it doesn't work out you don't owe him
his full season
salary as a practical matter under the
collective bargaining agreement
the lions were willing to jump pre-week
one which is why he went with detroit
in hindsight does he wish he'd gone
to kansas city they went with le'veon
bell after bell was cut by the jets bell
didn't work out peterson i think at
least would have contributed to the
cause i could see the chiefs being at
least interested
in peterson for 2021. there isn't a team
out there though that you look at miles
and say
adrian peterson would be the bell cow
he's the answer he's the guy
he's going to be a role player and the
problem is if you're a role player
you're not going to play the kind of
role you need to play to get 707 rushing
yards
in a given season and average that
amount for the next five i
look i i don't want
to do the typical knee jerk this guy's
delusional you have to be delusional
to make it in the nfl for as long as he
has i like the fact that the guy's
closing in on 36 and he's still holding
on to a dream
and he's still pursuing the dream and
he's still showing up every day and he's
putting in the work
necessary to get there and maybe he will
but if he doesn't there's no shame in
that he's still a hall of fame running
back
and i think the fact that he's holding
out that hope
to win a super bowl to pass him at smith
that's the thing that keeps him going
otherwise maybe he would just call it
quits
and be done yeah i i don't think he is
as delusional as
many people in his situation might be
because
when you look at it he's still pretty
productive i i don't know
if you could say all right you look at
him and you look at frank gore which one
would you rather have i mean i'd
probably rather have adrian peterson
if it comes down to it because if you're
talking about an older running back at
least
he still shows a little bit more
explosion where if you're looking at
frank gore and
don't get me wrong i have a ton of
respect for frank gore and how long he's
played in this league
but that's more two yards in a cloud of
dust at least
adrian peterson can break off a
seven-yard run a 10-yard run if he gets
the right amount of space maybe he gets
a 35-yard touchdown i just don't think
you can see that
from frank gore but i think based on the
way adrian peterson works in the way
that we know how much he's taking care
of his body to this point
in his career i don't think it's too
delusional for
him to think that yes he could eclipse
that mark
if he got the opportunity but mike like
you said it's about the opportunity
and frankly if you're a team i want the
guys who have less tread on those tires
yeah absolutely right especially because
if they're farther down on the depth
chart
they're contributing on special teams
they
are cheaper you don't have to worry
about the injury factor as much and you
also don't have to worry about
this notion that you're going to have a
guy on the sideline
who's thinking why am i not in the game
why am i not getting the ball i think
back to the first
game of the 2016 season when he
was 2017 i'm off by a year 2016 was his
last year with the vikings he was out
most of the season with
a knee injury 2017 saints and vikings he
was stewing on the sideline because he
wasn't getting the kind of opportunities
he thought he would get and he ended up
being traded by the saints
during that season so it's a tough
balance it's a tough call
and i think tampa bay would be a perfect
spot for him if they had a need because
you know he he'd fall under the tom
brady spell
maybe he'd start doing some of the tom
brady
methods of playability and avocado ice
cream and
find a way to extend his career to the
point where he'd like to make it to 40.
maybe have a 45 year old quarterback and
a
38 39 year old running back in tampa bay
that would require leonard fournette
moving on and i think frenette at this
point clearly a better option than
adrian peterson but
but again i i like the fact that the guy
still wants to play
and i agree with you i'd rather have him
than frank gore even though i do believe
frank gore is a first ballot hall of
famer for sharing the
the durability and production that we've
seen over the years
but you know we talked about smith a
couple of weeks ago in advance of the
super bowl and
adrian peterson not one of the names
that's on emmett smith's radar screen
when it comes to people who could catch
his record here's a little bit of what
we
talked to emmett about when we talked to
him in the few days before the super
bowl
is there anybody out there that you've
kind of flagged as this could be the guy
who eventually breaks my record it's too
early
it is too early in the game right now
frank gore is the guy that's still out
there running
and um i mean he's inching closer and
closer
but you know it's just too early to tell
in terms of all of the young backs that
are out there derek henry just came
went over 2 000 yards this year uh and
so he's quickly moving up the ladder
himself uh but it's just too early to
tell right now
um i would start looking at it uh when
players starting to get into 13 000
yards once you get to that 13 000 yard
mark
we'll see where you are and how your
body's feeling how you're holding up and
and and whether or not the team continue
to believe in you
and give you an opportunity to go and do
something pretty special
adrian peterson falls into that category
but was not mentioned by emmett smith
i think that emmett probably feels the
same way we do that
the opportunities just aren't going to
be there that the the spirit
may be willing the flesh may be strong
enough but if you don't find
a team that's going to give you the
chances you're never going to rack up
the yardage necessary to bridge that
3535 yard gap miles
well it just seemed like he really just
wanted to answer your question with
no and move on but then he kind of found
a way to be a little bit more polite
about it
but you know once you get to 13 000
yards yeah
maybe then we can start talking about it
and maybe he just forgot that adrian
peterson
has already gotten past that and that
you know he's shown that
yeah i still want to be able to do this
i still want to be out there i'm still
taking care of myself
but yeah i mean i think emmitt smith is
going to stay the russian king
for a long time i just don't know that
anybody else is just going to get those
opportunities at this point
and emmett has told us and this was from
last year prior to the super bowl that
he wants to be
alive when it happens he wants to
participate in the moment because
walter payton was gone when emmett smith
broke the record
and emmitt smith knows how much it would
have meant to him
to be able to celebrate that occasion
with the guy who had the record
before emmitt smith but the way the game
has gone you've got to play a long time
you've got you you've got to hope that
your team chooses to run the football
enough opportunities for you to gain the
yardage and you got to be good enough
and you got to stay healthy and you got
to check a lot of boxes
that makes it very difficult to check to
get to the point where you can pass
emmett smith hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports